have you ever had to interview for a job
or gone on a blind date or had to give a
presentation
if so you're well aware of the
importance of a first impression but how
do we make sure that a first impression
we make is a great one
hi i'm rich burnett for one dream and in
this episode of perspectives we hear
from a handful of experts on just that
the methods and psychology behind making
a great first impression
we begin now with some tips for
impressing a potential employer at a job
interview
spoiler alert don't try too hard
enjoy
[Music]
conveying information about one's
knowledge skills and experience
in a resume or application is usually
straightforward
because applicants can point to their
educational history
certifications and previous experience
but conveying an impression of being
likable is more difficult
although people sometimes do it by
listing interests and activities
that make them seem like a nice person
but most of people's efforts to appear
likable
occur during the job interview
and applicants do many of the same kinds
of things to get the interviewer to like
them
that they do in other face-to-face
interactions
for example they laugh at the
interviewer's jokes
try their hand at a little humor
themselves
attempt to seem modest about their
accomplishments
and they may even pretend to like the
interviewer
whether they do or not anything that
gives the impression that they're a nice
likable person
the challenge
is that there's sometimes a trade-off
between appearing likable and appearing
competent
research shows that the more people do
things to make themselves seem likable
the less competent they may appear and
the more they try to look competent
the less they come across as friendly
and likable
both sets of impressions are important
and job applicants have to find the
optimal mix
do applicants self presentations and job
interviews actually work in terms of
increasing their likelihood of getting a
job
absolutely
impression management can certainly
backfire if people's self presentations
are obvious or clumsy but studies show
that self-presentation generally works
employers want to hire competent likable
people
so applicants who purposefully say and
do things to foster the impression that
they're competent and likable are
certainly more likely to be hired than
applicants who don't
but research offers an interesting
qualification of this finding
applicants self-presentations have a
stronger effect on interviewers
impressions of them
if the job interview
is unstructured rather than structured
and impression management tactics in the
interview context have been analyzed in
other scholarly studies
for example
a 2002 study by alex ellis goes into a
bit more detail about the importance of
self-promotion and ingratiation in
successful job interviews
for starters ellis breaks these two
large categories into various specific
tactics for example he breaks
ingratiation into two specific tactics
opinion conformity
and other enhancement
opinion conformity refers to stating
beliefs that one could reasonably assume
the other person would also hold
other enhancement is more
straightforward flattery saying
something positive about that person
in addition ellis study identifies a
third broad category of impression
management tactics called defensive
tactics
defensive tactics include excuses
justifications and even apologies as
ways to protect or repair
reputation
here's how the study worked
the researchers obtained audio tapes of
practice interviews conducted by real
employers
the interviews were conducted by
different recruiters but all involved
the same 14 questions
119 structured interview audio tapes
were coded by two trained research
assistants who listened carefully for
the use of those tactics
what were the commonly used tactics and
which worked best
well first it's worth noting that all
but three of this entire sample of
interviewees used at least one of the
impression management tactics
self-promotion ingratiation and
defensive tactics
people were actively trying to manage
impressions while answering interview
questions
but which of those tactics worked
both self-promotion and ingratiation
tactics had a small positive and
statistically significant correlation
with interview evaluations
so using these tactics was associated
with higher evaluations by the
interviewer
defensive tactics on the other hand had
a much lower correlation that wasn't
significant
taken as a whole this study suggests
that informal interview contexts
engaging in both self-promotion and a
bit of opinion conformity is likely to
create the most positive impression
the extent that you as the job candidate
look attentive and enthusiastic about
the job will help sway a personnel
officer to select you for the job so
all right what does that attentive
enthusiasm look like behaviorally well
as far as what you might need to do dr
ronald riggio says that your behavior is
easy as pie
the word pie stands for
poise interest and expressiveness p-i-e
poise interest and expressiveness you
convey these pie qualities through an
attentive forward lean like you see in
immediacy confidence looking people in
the eye when you speak but of course not
staring in their eyes more variation in
your voice tone and gesturing when you
speak and being expressive with your
smiles and just generally showing
positive emotion
and not showing negative emotion even
when you're talking about things like a
hated former boss looking negative never
helps
but of course you cannot be so
incredibly joyful and so positive that
you seem like you're kind of
psychologically unstable or manic all
right but the opposite behaviors leaning
back no eye contact yawning checking
your watch and the aforementioned
negative behaviors can be job killers
and
cell phone leave it at home but if you
have to bring it turn it off and keep it
out of sight those things will also be
helpful
audiences perk up and listen when you
first start to talk
and they listen when it sounds like you
are winding down
that moment when you first start to talk
that's called the moment of primacy it's
when you're making your first impression
the audience is getting oriented and
deciding whether this speech is worth
listening to
or whether they'd rather check their
messages on their phones
and they're not tired yet
they're all listening to the first few
sentences
so take advantage of that moment you'll
want to spend some time thinking about a
catchy way to start so that you are
excited to deliver that opening
that can help with nerves so that you
are projecting confidence which helps
with your ethos if your opening is
catchy and tells the audience how
they're going to benefit from listening
to your speech then you're giving them a
reason to care and starting to create
that relationship with them engaging
them that's pathos
and you will also want to begin the
process of making your logical argument
in the first paragraph of the speech by
introducing the conclusion you plan to
reach hit that theme from the very
beginning it's the first time they will
hear it and since they're listening they
will remember it
that's logos
we also know that audiences listen to
the end of the speech
it's the very last thing you say to them
so whatever you say then is also likely
to stick with them
this is called the moment of recency
another place to hit your theme
we remember best the last thing that we
hear so you'll want to circle back to
the central message you introduced in
your moment of primacy
social scientists have long known that
humans like other animals express power
through open expansive postures
you could think about this in nature if
you're a peacock and you want to express
power you unfurl those feathers or if
you are a lion you shake your mane and
you roar you stalk around and take up
space you don't run and hide you let the
world know that you're there
same with humans maya angelou once wrote
stand up straight and realize who you
are that you tower over your
circumstances i love that
a psychologist named amy cuddy has
studied the impact of body language and
public speaking and she's found that
audiences make snap judgments about a
speaker within the first two minutes of
a speech based on what that speaker is
doing physically
the speaker is using open expansive
postures which she calls power poses
then the audience is more likely to
assess them as credible
if instead the speaker is using closed
protective submissive postures then the
audience is going to think that the
speaker doesn't know what he's talking
about
those closed submissive postures that
undercut your credibility are the
postures we retreat to when we're
feeling scared and we need to soothe
ourselves think about the small child
curled up in a ball or the speaker with
her her arms and legs protecting her
core if you're shielding your core it
indicates that you feel under attack
or sometimes you see yourself through
repetitive motion think of that small
child rocking back and forth sucking her
thumb
or the speaker who rocks or fidgets or
plays with hair or jewelry or clothes
all those habits can get in the way of
your credibility
now remember
pace is how quickly or slowly you speak
we typically measure pace in words per
minute and if we take silence and
semantics into consideration we can
create a general guideline of an optimal
english speaking pace at somewhere
between 140 and 175 words a minute
but remember typical speaking pace
varies from culture to culture and from
situation to situation
when you speak at a faster pace you
demand more of your audience the
audience has to work to keep up with you
which can be helpful in some instances
but if your pace gets too fast as it
often can when you're nervous
the audience might not be able to keep
up
so if you feel your heart pounding
before you begin to speak
remember to breathe deeply and remind
yourself to take it slow
now going at a slower pace than the
cultural norm can engage an audience and
sometimes even surprise them
you get to choose what you think
if you catch yourself thinking negative
thoughts like this is going to be a
disaster
then stop yourself and try intentionally
thinking another thought instead
choose one that is true that you can
believe
you could try
i took the time to prepare for this i
have thought about who my audience is
i have something to offer them
i'm going to offer it
remember that this does not have to be a
perfect show if you have taken the time
to think about the things we've been
talking about then your presentation is
going to have value
you are going to be offering something
worthwhile
your audience is going to benefit from
the experience of listening to you
you are doing something to make the
world a better place
now
go to it knock them dead and have a
great time while you're doing it there
is nothing quite like
knowing you have something to say
saying it
and then listening to your audience
cheer
and that is what i hope for you
hey thanks for watching if you'd like to
learn more about any of the topics in
this episode the full list of series
that these clips came from is in the
description below you can watch all the
full series now on onedrive.com and
don't forget to subscribe to this
youtube channel turn on notifications
and you'll get an alert every time we
post a new episode of perspectives